hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar gene
inactivation
by crisper i modulate gene expression
with pam
anchor targeting i'm alexis cross of
labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labberts
and brought to you by horizon discovery
to learn more about our sponsor
please visit horizondiscovery.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you may
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation i'd
like to now welcome our speaker
dr c smith a product manager for gene
demodulation
at horizon discovery for a full
biography on our speaker
please click on the biography tab at the
top right of your screen
steve welcome sir we're happy to have
you
you may now begin your presentation
thank you steve for that wonderful and
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so steve let's get started we've already
got some amazing questions coming in
from the audience
so we'll start with this one now this
first one is going to be a two-part
question
do you see any increase in off-target
repression with the more potent
repressor
and the second part was is would crisper
eye
with pool synthetic sgrna be less
specific than using an
individual guide rna
oh right yeah alexis thanks man and
thank you for that question this is
something that is we've been sharing
this with with folks a little bit um you
know through the development
this has come up a number of times so
thanks for asking that in the in the
forum here
um it you know in order for uh a
off-target effect in order for a a um
a guide to to have an off-target effect
it would have to be an off-target
binding to another regulatory region
so that really shrinks the the space for
for off targeting
um we have definitely performed rna-seq
on our on our data sets to compare the
specificity
of our repressor um to the crab
repressor
and we've found that that there's just
really very very minimal
um bystander effects resulting from
from using these guys um we did look at
the pooling of guide rnas versus
individuals
as well and really didn't see any
increase
in in differentially expressed uh
transcripts so
uh so uh yes i mean we definitely offer
the pools and individual reagents so you
can follow up on
correlation and address any off-target
concerns uh the other thing this is
that's come up
a bit is whether there's any you know
truly non-specific actions
as far as you know acting on on next
door neighbor jeans or across the street
neighbor jeans
um and we just really because of that
limited window for efficacy where these
guides need to be placed in relation to
the transcription start site
we really um don't see any uh any
uh evidence of these effects so it's a
reasonable concern and something we're
certainly keeping our eye on so um yeah
i think the beauty of the
the system is the specificity in large
part and you have to have kind of
prolonged contact for that
crispr mediated crispr immediate
repression so um yeah it's cool thanks
for the thanks for the question
of course so moving on to our next
question you mentioned the time course
for safely and transfected cells
how long do you expect the repression
mediated by dcas9
cell 1 sds3 mrna to persist for uh
yeah right yeah thanks i not have
mentioned that in passing
so we see really robust transcriptional
repression that comes
on very very quickly as you're giving it
kind of a large bolus of
reagents and then this uh we recommend
this approach for those
short endpoint assays in the two to four
day range
uh i'd say is the is the safe um
window to be looking at with when using
the the mrna
along with the synthetic single guides
and continuing on with um repression
what level of repression should i expect
to see with crispr i
and how does the level compare to fi rna
effects
yeah sure so you know this is um
the level of transcriptional repression
with crispr eye is gonna
you know like dealing with these pesky
biological systems right so you're going
to have some variants depending on your
gene target
cell line time point of analysis etc
uh we definitely see you know comes
online quickly the
the target gene repression is maximal in
the 48 to 96 hour uh sort of window and
we we really
we've seen that 50 to 80 and i called it
about 60 to 80 percent knocked down
uh during that time um
so yeah so so this is this is
definitely somewhat less than we
observed with our si rna reagents
we expect those usually in the 80 to
sort of 95
knock down area great
now our next question is it possible to
use crispr and crisper eye together
for activating a gene and inactivating
another one
at the same time wow
cool
yeah so kind of looking at simultaneous
activation and
um and interference there's some some
technical hurdles
um there as far as the the guide design
and
you know controlling which genes to turn
on and which means to turn off when
mixing them all
so um so at this point no and at this
point we're not able to do simultaneous
uh
switch on switch off across across
various gene targets
but it's a super cool idea and something
certainly i'm sure us and others are are
keen on
on uh and seeing if there's a way to
accomplish that because that would be
would be super cool
and so our next question steve do you
have
the crispr mod crisper eye as an
inducible system
right we don't we don't have an
inducible uh
flavor of this at this time
great thank you so we do want to just
remind our audience you know we've
received so many great questions in
today
um any questions that we don't have time
for or unable to get to today
they'll be answered by steve um or a
member of horizon discovery
via the email address that you
registered for this webinar with
so steve let's move on to our next
question
how are the synthetic guides or
synthetic
excuse me how are the synthetic guides
or synthetic guides plus
dcas9 cell 1 sds3
introduced into the cells is it for
example nucleophile
yeah so um yeah thanks i might not have
mentioned that well
in passing but we've done both lipid
transfections
and nuclear infections with mrna plus
the
the single guides so whatever your cells
would uh would tolerate the best will
will work
wonderful thank you now so for the
multiplexing of many sgrna against
different targets
was that done with a single sg rna gene
or
the pools of three
yeah um good question thanks so this is
um
so it was when going to the multiplexing
we dialed it into the best performing
individual guide
so we suggest starting with the pooled
guide approach and coming in
and um and starting with those pools and
um
and then experimenting with them
individually
and dialing in the best performing uh
individual component
and then using that as part of the the
um
the multiplexed pool approach
great thank you so our next question
does the crisper eye guide
share the same sequence of the horizon
crispr a off the shelf
products oh right yeah good question
um thanks for that they're they're not
so we have to they have to nest
on on sort of opposite sides of the
transcription start site
so the the crispr a guides um you know
are just
upstream and the crisper eye guides uh
sit just just downstream of that to kind
of have the
the right uh actions uh on transcription
so um yeah so they're they're close
they're their neighbors but i know
different different
different targeted areas across the
genomic dna
right thank you so much for that
clarification and
so steve it looks like we may have time
for for one more question before we
we close out this webinar so how far
from the tss is the grr excuse me
the grnas need to be designed to achieve
gene significant knockdown using this
system
yeah so right yeah related um they're
just you know they're within like
300 uh base pairs downstream so
they're very they're nested very close
um to that transcription
start site and again this this comes out
of the
published uh algorithms uh that the
from the from the weisman lab
wonderful and it looks like we've got
another question in here for you
do you recommend only single guide rna
rather than a two-part crrna or
tracker rna yeah sure um
so yeah it's a good question um
for this system we do we were using the
the single gun rnas uh the the two part
the crisper tracers rnas
um would work with this system but we're
not we're
the only guides we're offering are the
synthetic single guides
um so yeah we've we've tried a bit in
passing uh
it seems that the market is you know is
moving to um
to the synthetic single guy more and
more so we've leaned on that for this
product
menu but um we we have both across
across our other products and we see
quite similar results across them so so
yeah sure
if that was if there was a reason that
that was the better option then yes
great thank you so much steve um do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we go for the day
um no no thank you really thanks for all
the great interaction and great
questions
um please feel free to reach out to
myself or our tech services group
again we'd love to help you get going
with with crispr i
uh super excited about this and just to
see what um what comes of it in the
months and years to come it's been a fun
development and it's it's
great to see it go uh out into the wild
today so
uh so yeah we'd love to hear more from
you and please
feel free to email or call our us
anytime and talk more
so thanks thanks alexis appreciate the
hosting and thanks everybody for joining
thank you again steve for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lavertz and
our sponsor horizon discovery for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience again for joining us
and for their interesting questions as a
reminder questions that we did not have
time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration so please
feel free to keep those questions coming
in
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now stay stay healthy
stay safe
thank you everyone bye